this is going to beat me okay
I am hyped are you hi brother
we have been on the road for so
I think I'm going to go batshit crazy in
the few seconds I mean I am going to
crack just looking at all the lines
goodbye and all the sides and all these
advertisements for fireworks it's insane
it's totally insane
I mean God brother how long have we been
on the road
one hour 30 minutes
I'm gonna die
you know I'm guessing a nice thing about
this is that you know I personally would
not be able to get out of Illinois you
know I came to find my way at my own
house but my brother here is just so
good a resourceful that you know he is
really good at directions in the you
know all that stuff yes they're so you
know just special shout-out to end
special things because without him I
like wouldn't be able to get there at
all so this is actually really really
cool damn straight
damn straight
all right so we're in Michigan I don't
know how that happened if you don't
believe me here take a look there's a
there's a lighthouse you know because
only Michigan has lighthouses and we're
gonna try and figure out just how the
health has happened
I'm very angry at my brother so yeah
what the hell are we doing in Michigan
slightly for everything's fine just just
great except for the fact that we're in
Michigan well haven't you ever wanted to
see the lighthouse State is that is that
what this it's just really known for
lighthouses I don't I don't know what
Michigan is known for cherries and Bob
yeah lighthouses houses okay
hurry down this road for a couple miles
and it's reduced that one lane use all
these columns but what there's there's
no construction there's no nothing it's
just one lay like that the same sheets
going on over there always been more
than that this has been six miles now
the six miles of no construction just
just keeping us in one lane it's for the
greater good I think they're just doing
it to piss us off I think they just got
higher than that you don't be funny was
just reduce it all down to one LaHaye
they don't be funny and no reason and
everybody will do it because they have
to oh my god there it is actual
construction well they doing what are
they doing there they're doing nothing
there doing nothing what what was that
guy doing there just taking up the road
and now we go back to the two lane I was
crazy house miles and miles are just two
trucks bullshit actually 10 miles to be
10 10 miles for just two stinkin truck
tonight this stupid juice thing is going
slow front front cooled back fuck WABAC
bucket and my construction it's fucking
Quebec or something fuck Quebec prowlers
god I'm so bored say something damn it
you're supposed to be keeping me in good
conversation just say something I'm
driving oh he's driving that's all the
conversation I get here he's driving
whoopsie fucking dude you don't want to
sing a song let's sing a song so sing a
little Gilbert and Sullivan how about
then we are going to sing The Mikado
right now three little maids from squall
we start no we're not you start
Hey Little Miss Chloe cadets go girls
can be an affirmative end with college
leave in the middle school everything
this is also fun
poor little martyr cut for little
article though you will never know why
he might
well we already song every song we know
every tune we know done everything that
we can think about doing just so boring
roads boring the trees are boring you're
boring you are so boring
do something say something yeah just
something
ooh he guessed he gasped no no side
that's even better inside that's like a
gasp backward oh I'm fucking evil do
something you fucking moron
Rob I'm sorry oh hey that's not called
for
oh come on Rob cut a guy a break I
didn't know any better
oh come on man I just I wasn't thinking
hey what if I drove the rest of the way
there's a cedar point largest
rollercoaster is outside of Disney
physics legs
and the zero point lately
Kelly - say something
like did know
first thing ever to say in the past four
hours that's a fountain of conversation
that's a geyser whoa Danny stand back
shit
I'm sitting here driving doing all the
drivin driving all the way from
Cleveland trying to keep our hopes up
fight the boredom you can't say one
fucking thing in the way a conversation
oh c'mon I'll have to talk either see
how you like it
fucking silence two can play that game
boys guy
Syria by Canton
total silence
you
if I was to kill you and bury your body
is there any particular place that you
would want to be buried
you know like a religious thing I mean
are there any certain areas that you
need to be buried in or shouldn't be
buried in like a Jewish thing or are you
Jewish
we were baptized Roman Catholic
I mean I'm not Jewish
No
Pennsylvania pencil guide this better be
fucking worth it Vania whoo
okay I'm barely in Pennsylvania they
have some very strange road signs tell
tale gay
beware of aggressive drivers slowed down
save a life
careful bridge maybe I see Wendy
Pennsylvania turn into my mother they
actually have these spaces so that you
can keep one car lengths behind
it looks like a plank pac-man
Philadelphia's fucked up I come in empty
to the press and say have you decided to
do this Elena Styles to save you having
to do in our video challenging me to do
a video game review it's just me saying
like you know have you decided to do a
nostalgic movie and you say yes I'm
gonna do whatever you choose and then
you say now are you gonna do a video
game I'm like don't want a video game is
your department I was thinking you have
the rocky soundtrack I'm sure you do
yeah yeah oh yeah let's do orbit bring
it on yeah and they play the rocky music
like we get ready to fight there we go
we just have a silly slow-mo fight
you know like we even do the sound
effects of rule yeah you know you beat
me and at the end I say alright alright
we'll do a video game but mark my words
this isn't over huh and then ask well I
can't get back on the highway or
something it's gonna be like that
playing rocky fly with people are there
any ways outside Oh it'll be like you
should say that EE same Irene's outside
let's do it right now right here my
rings outside but you know what my rings
outside let's do it yeah there's only
one thing it's kind of a side thing but
I just think we should really put in
there and here just yet the idea will
get Captain s in on this too and I don't
know exactly what he would be doing but
the referee yeah I would imagine he
would be more like trying to be the
peacemaker and what I should end the
fight yet then it would be the three of
us all fighting there in the parking lot
digital press hi nice to meet you
thanks a lot your dad you're familiar
with the good the bad the ugly parts of
it yes yeah well we all up I'll put the
seat on
basically your idea would just be to
mimic that I can do I can walk see you
see how it's got the multiple shots I
can literally walk in between you guys
because you can re-edit this however you
want I can just train the camera on your
eyes you know on your faces you can give
me the looks and I can walk to the next
person the whole time you free you're
still basically standing in the triangle
okay all right okay listen hard it looks
like the nerd not eating his cake I'm
trying to eat his cake even his take is
defeating me that's good victory
my god
you'll be